I'm not the first person that's saying
sharing this quote it's been shared a
billion times you know don't ask what
your country can do for you ask for you
know what you can do for your country I
think it's more we got to kind of go
back to that Hey listen guys like what
are you doing for America okay yeah I
think we're and this is where
conversation helps I you got to get a
job you can't go on the Dole there's you
know if I were a king I'd say there's a
lot yes yes that's it we're on the same
page but uh but I don't but we've
encouraged people to say immigrants are
dirty immigrants and so yeah now let me
come outside oh come on you don't think
there's a sentiment in America I don't
no I'm talking about let me see what
he's gonna say I don't Mexican rapists
Mexicans are rape no those who are
rapists that they're sending their
rapists here yeah we shouldn't have them
here yes I agree with that okay you know
the the most like you know Bill Maher
said something very interesting when you
were on with them and Bill Maher said to
your face Bill Maher said most Muslims
are not terrorists but most terrorists
are what Muslims yeah he said that do
you and and your sinner said okay how do
you you didn't argue that you're like
that's right okay so but for for for for
for you to say you were saying that uh
you know immigrants are rapists give me
a break you don't think people have more
of an anti-immigrant sentiment today
than they would have 30 years ago no I
don't okay I disagree I don't and I'm an
immigrant I'm the Immigrant talking I'm
not a white guy that's privileged I grew
up in a family that went to Vanderbilt
and it's got you know lived in a nice
Community that's not this guy I'm the
Immigrant listen let me tell you when I
experience discrimination and I'll give
it to you when I was in the Army and I'm
shooting a rifle it's a funny story but
it's a true story
I'm shooting a rifle and I got the M16
on my nose my drill sergeant comes and
says I've never seen a nose like that in
my life before he says where are you
from I said I'm from Iran and he says
man that's a massive note I said I
appreciate it I said drill Serge I got
to tell you something though he says
what's that I said it'll take me seven
thousand dollars to make my nose look
like yours it'll take you Millions to
make yours look like mine right it
starts cracking up we have a
relationship together I go to Alabama
I'm at a waffle house 1997. I'm going to
Panama City to party at Club La Villa
and spinnakers apparently Club
Louisville is going out of business
right now or they went out of business
on the way there to Alabama I sit there
at the Waffle House
everyone's white waitress shows up
she keeps looking at me like she's never
seen a creature like this before
and I said ma'am is there something
going on you're okay sir where are you
from a Sam from Iran you from Iran Iran
she says where'd you run she says yes
I'm Ryan I said yes I'm from Iran she
says uh what are you doing here in
Alabama I said I'm in your army I'm in
the U.S army they let you in the US Army
yes
what are you doing in the US Army I said
can I feel comfortable telling you she
says yeah of course I said I'm a spy I'm
taking all your content and I'm taking
it back to Iran to train our soldiers
a little bit of that happens yeah but to
sit there and say oh my God I'm a victim
feel sorry for me give me a break we
have victims and Adam's gonna police
this what I said was I think there's
more anti-americ cinnamon today than 30
years ago yes or no you did say that but
but you also said that every generation
we have to kind of Trace back and and
fulfill what happened in the prior
generation before that yes talked about
you being Italian Irish immigrant the
Jews and the blacks yeah everything
that's happened since that but the
sentiment that you're talking about are
you basically saying because you went
off on Trump with the [ __ ] comments
right yeah [ __ ] whole country is that
what you're referring to you're saying
that the sentiment against immigrants
is that where you're going with this
yeah I mean I can't look ahead far
enough to say where people will judge us
in the future I can guess based on
history they'll judge us for something
though in terms of how we treated people
maybe how we treated immigrants I don't
know I'm not comfortable with the with
the with the rhetoric I see about anger
immigration in this country I would say
the rhetoric have to be has to be more
fact-based because we're going back to
where you started the conversation both
sides should say we have a problem and
that problem goes back to the Congress
to say the laws should allow more rapid
and more sort of dispersed decision
making about whether a 19 year old who
wants a job should be allowed across the
border and my answer is no
you know statement to you so you know uh
I've been to restaurants where it's
packed 24 7. you go there okay and then
you'll go on Yelp and you'll read a
review this restaurant sucks the owner
is terrible their customer service is
horrible they're gonna go out of
business
and I'll be in the restaurant I'm like
dude if this review was right why the
hell am I in line for 20 minutes
what the hell is going on with this
restaurant that's supposed to be the
worst restaurant in the world if America
treats immigrants so bad why did we have
a record breaking two million people
came through the Border were so horrible
at immigrants if we're so terrible at
treating immigrants what do you think
you could stop twisting my comments I
did not say we traded immigrants poorly
I think we if you look at things like
access I wish we could rewind this thing
I said people's thinking and attitudes
about immigrants has changed to the
negative because people like you keep
saying it oh for God's sakes you ask
because we keep saying okay so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]